Today we've actually unlocked the next step
along the Teign Estuary Trail. It's been a
project that's long been wanted by people in
Teignmouth and Newton Abbot. It's about getting
a cycle way all the way from Teignmouth through to
Newton Abbot along the side of the Teign Estuary.
For a long time it's been stuck we've got
Planning Permission but we don't have the money,
we don't have the land, so we can't ask for
the money. What we've done today is opened
up a way of actually getting that land and
building a business case so we'll create a
right of access along the side of the Teign
Estuary and a business case so we can appeal
to government to get the project completed. Today
we brought forward a million pounds of community
infrastructure Levy money paid by developers to
help us develop new things like cycle paths to
actually make this project happen and this is
a fantastic collaboration between Teignbridge,
Devon County, the Teign Estuary Trail campaign
group and Bishopsteignton Parish Council,
and together we're making a real difference for
local residents in the area. So the next steps
now we've got the money allocated is to do the
work to build the business case to prove that
it's going to be a good investment to purchase
the bits of land along the side of the river and
then to make a right of way through that, so
at least we've got a footpath that will be an
off-road footpath from Bishopsteignton through
to Passage House in Kingsteignton on the side
of the river on through into Newton Abbot. That
in itself will be extremely valuable when we've
got that ready and we've got a business case we
can then appeal to the next round of government
funding - whenever that may be - and say "here's
our project we're ready to go, give us the money."